thank you all for coming to the talk i
wanted to start off by just saying thank
you to alex and all the team
it's been kind of a
wish list of mine to be able to get to
come to the conference
but to speak is a really great honor so
i'm very thankful to be here today
so today i want to bring you all on a
journey with me similar journey to the
way that i started when i became working
at the company that i work at today
literati
so
many times we look at litter and we have
a question about what does it mean to
you to me i didn't see it it blended
into the background it was something
that i passed by every day when i walked
around or when i drove by it i just kind
of said oh look at that or i didn't even
see it right our brains get trained to
just look past things and not even see
it
so today i want to bring you on a
journey and go through the same kind of
journey that i went through where now i
get to see the litter so bringing the
unseen to be seen
so this is also a talk where i want
audience interaction there's a couple
places so if you're you know software
developers you're not used to like doing
things during talks like please get
ready because i'm going to ask for some
interaction
all right so i want to start off
in
the audience if you have things just
shout it out loud what do you see in
this picture
cigarette butts okay
a can of red bull
yeah okay all kinds of things right but
it's litter right it's the stuff that
you see every day or maybe you don't see
and you walk by it every day
and so what i want to talk about is
what litter means to the world
so it's a global problem and i want to
use this bottle
as an example so one of my co-workers
actually picked this up in hawaii on a
litter pickup at the beach in hawaii now
the problem with that is this bottle was
from malaysia so it transported all the
way from malaysia to hawaii and then
ended up in this state
so we're talking about a massive problem
and
maybe the next couple slides are going
to depress you a little bit but i want
you to get to understand the scope of
the problem we're dealing with here it's
a global problem
so we have pictures of litter in our
database from all over the world
mongolia
saudi arabia
fiji i mean there's no part of the globe
that we don't have some idea of what
litter looks like and it looks different
in every part of the world
but it doesn't even discriminate across
famous places this is from a research
study we did right in front of the
pyramids where we found litter in front
of the pyramids in egypt
this was a litter that was picked up by
our community member right in the middle
of the forbidden city in china in
beijing
everest base camp
near india
times square
some of you might recognize some of the
iconic floor the ground right these
aren't pictures of the places but what
litter you walk by maybe when you go
there the eiffel tower
this is near where nelson mandela was
wrongfully imprisoned for so many years
in south africa
this is the iconic mosaic ground near
copacabana beach in rio de janeiro with
a cigarette butt proudly displayed right
in the middle of it
red square in moscow russia i mean the
list goes on and on and on we have
almost every major city or monument in
the world we have litter that has been
documented near it
it can be overwhelming so
pictures like this if you've been in you
know
you know third world countries or places
that are just even around here right
place scenes like this can be
overwhelming and before i started
working in this industry and seeing
these pictures
you know it was numb to me but now i
can't unsee pictures like this where on
the side of the road the litter that is
dropped on the ground ends up in the
waterways ends up in piles ends up in
massive problems
so
i also want to point out that
it can even be artistic and this image
actually was the very first image that
ended up in our database
that our founder snapped it on instagram
and what started our company he took
added a hashtag literati to
this picture and then other people
started doing it and then eventually he
was like hey we have a lot of
information about where litter is in the
world i wonder if we could make a
company out of this
so
we actually did an artistic exhibit that
traveled the country i don't know if any
of you saw it but
where we took the pictures of litter and
there was there was art made out of it
but the thing is once you start kind of
being involved and once you see the
unseen and once you
be ex once you're exposed to the scale
of the problem that exists
you know you see it everywhere right
does anyone want to take a guess where
these pictures were from
there you go outside
so yesterday i walked in between the two
front doors and found 45 pieces of
litter right
so it's everywhere and that's an area
where you know
they're trying to keep it clean so
imagine what happens when they're not
so i want to talk about
the scale and this is where i want your
interaction
so this is a picture of the great
pacific garbage patch
so it is a floating island of trash in
the middle of the pacific ocean
okay and one of the things that we
struggle with as a company is there's so
many numbers and statistics and things
that
should demonstrate the problem to the
world but we struggle to figure out
which is the one that is quite going to
capture people's imaginations
and so you're going to be part of my
experimentation today in a couple ways
this is one of them i'm going to show
you some statistics about this great
pacific garbage patch and i want you to
raise your hand when you get it when you
understand the scope of what we're
dealing with here okay
all right
and just keep them raised that would be
great so
to understand the scale of this that
little blob on the right hand side is
north america
right
to understand the scale of this so
there are five
five trillion 250 billion
pieces of litter estimated in the great
garbage patch okay
now that's about 15 000 per adult in the
united states
okay in some ways they can't even these
are guesses because they can't study it
it's so thick
it's 1.6 million square kilometers
which is roughly the size of the country
of iran
anybody okay i've got most of you so far
all right i'll get you on the next set
of next set of things okay
um but i mentioned it was the great
pacific garbage patch you can put your
hands down sorry thank you
i appreciate that yes um
i mentioned it was the great pacific
garbage patch so am i just being coy
with that well no there's one of them in
each of our oceans
not as big as the one in the pacific we
as americans hold the claim of the
largest garbage patch right we like to
be the biggest at everything but there's
one of these in every one of the major
sort of places where the ocean congeals
right
and so
this is just
an
incalculable problem we just deal with
huge numbers and they just roll off our
tongues and we don't even we can't even
grasp the scale of them so we don't know
where to start
but what we're trying to do is
not solve the whole thing but be a part
of the solution
so there are real consequences to litter
okay and i should have been clear at the
beginning i'm only talking about litter
not waste
so there are there's a difference there
the waste is the stuff that you put in
your trash can and then it gets taken
off
right litter is everything that doesn't
make it to the trash can ends up on the
ground okay so all of these statistics
are just about litter not about waste
that's a whole separate depressing
conversation
so some of the consequences and again
this is another opportunity for you to
raise your hands when you feel like this
hits me in a deep way okay because
there's a lot of really sobering
statistics okay and again keep your
hands up if you would
so seven billion tons of litter goes
into the oceans every year
seven billion sixty percent of that
comes from litter
not waste litter just the stuff that
gets dropped on the ground and
eventually makes its way into the oceans
one million animals per year are
estimated to die because of litter not
because of waste not because of
pollution or all the other things that
animals can run into but
just litter
so each cigarette butt that's littered
takes 10 years to decompose from the
time that it's dropped
and in indonesia alone we did a study
100 billion cigarette butts are littered
each year not smoked littered much more
are smoked
okay
and they did a study in the united
kingdom where
they studied how much
got sort of thrown or blown out of cars
and ended up on the sides of highways
83 trash bags per mile
was was littered
on the sides of highways
all right and now for the rest of you
who haven't gotten your hands up yet i'm
speaking now to the people who are
monetarily focused
so in the united states alone cities
spend 200 billion dollars a year
on litter not waste just litter to
mitigate it
that's roughly three percent of our
federal budget
the equivalent of that
so it's equivalent to the transportation
parks and nasa budgets combined
this is a big problem folks and then if
it haven't gotten you yet
that's enough to feed about 36 million
people a year
according to the estimates of my local
food bank
so we're talking about a really large
problem with a lot of ramifications
and yet
with the scope of what we're dealing
with
there's no data there isn't anything
that cities are able to really latch on
to
well except ours hopefully right um
that helps solve this problem all that
money that i just mentioned was spent
just
however they could without any sort of
direct correlation or rationale just
throwing money at the problem and they
throw a lot of money at the problem
but what we're trying to provide is
accurate data so that cities and brands
and ngos and federal governments all
around the world are able to make
informed decisions to spend the money
wisely to
help
mitigate this problem that we know
exists now all you know exists
but it's hard to do so what do we see
now we're a technology company
and i'm speaking at a technology
conference so
i'm going to
pivot a little bit into the technology
for a bit so what do we see when we look
at this image
we see we use a lot of computer vision
to be able to look at this picture and
identify what is in the picture
to understand not just that there was
litter in that location where the
picture was taken
but also
what the composition was of the litter
in the picture
so
we have our own taxonomy that we
describe litter yes that's a thing i
didn't realize it was a thing before i
started working in this industry but it
is so we look at that red bull can
and it's not just a red bull can it's
not just crumpled it's not just thrown
in the ground it's not just a piece of
litter
we give it a category a material an
object and we even can recognize the
brand off of the off the can we go
further than that
and then we can also ascribe to it a
weight
and a volume
and figure out what the parent company
of the
brand was and then in what category that
brand mostly operates
and then since we work with groups and
institutions all over the world
we
correlate all of our information to
you know international taxonomies like
csiro which is the
like national science foundation
equivalent in australia osbar the
european union the national open smear
oceanic and atmospheric administration
there we go got it um which is good old
usa and then organizations like break
free from plastic
who all have their own external
taxonomies as well so we can speak their
language as well because we're dealing
with a global problem and so we have to
speak globally we don't just work in the
united states we work all over the world
to try to solve this problem
so we have a ton of data right and so
this picture was from our database as of
august 5th when we had 12 million we
have about 15 million pieces of litter
documented today
and this map i could probably just leave
up and just stare at together for a
couple minutes because it's so
fascinating to me i actually have it on
the wall of our office and i look at it
almost every day
and i find really interesting things in
here but
we have a broad scope of data but you
know it's never enough there's always
more information that we can pull out
more places that we haven't quite seen
and when we deal with cities there's a
higher need for
sort of
more real-time data
right just understanding that there's
litter there well they know that they
want to know where do i go pick it up so
i'll deal with that in a second so we
have a lot of data
and a lot of that is due to our amazing
community now again it's a world like i
was just talking with someone at lunch
there are worlds and problems that we
don't interact with so we don't know
that they're there and then when we get
into the communities and we talk to
people at conferences like this and we
get to hear the problems we get to see
that there are amazing people doing
amazing work all over the world
and we have an amazing community so
i have i was shocked to find out that
there are people in our community and we
have an app that people can go and
document litter people pick up and
document over a thousand pieces of
litter a day
all around the world in 180 countries we
have users that go and make it their
life's work to go and document the
litter around their area to try to
impact change this is a group in berlin
this is the mandatory cute kids picture
from singapore
but we have an amazing community that is
enabling us to provide data to the world
to help solve this problem
so we take that data
and then we can correlate it with other
data sets and we can actually start to
predict litter volume this is the city
of moscow where we did a recent study
and we were able to take the data that
we figured out through our
targeted research
methodology and we're able to correlate
that and then create a predictive model
to
explore where we think the higher
density of litter is in the city of
moscow again
nobody the the cities of the cities
around the world that we interact with
have nothing like this they have no idea
they know there's litter they know it's
everywhere but they don't know where it
actually is and so we're able to give
them a data set that they can actually
do something about and do something with
and so we can also do things like study
policy impact so
as an example
the city of austin if they go and change
their litter bins
sorry i work with someone who
comes from england so they call them
men's
but trash cans okay so if they change
their type of trash can and they want to
investigate did that work
or if they impose a new fine for a
litter thing how are they going to know
if it works today they don't they just
hope it does they just say well i think
there's less litter i'm walking around
the other day it looked like i didn't
see a trash anything so it's probably
better
but we do targeted research studies in
an area and we you know do a sampling
methodology and a whole bunch of stuff
that i'm not going to get into but we
we do we take all of that information
about what we found and then we can
explain to them well this is actually
the impact of that policy we can do
before and after and get and get a
really good picture of what the change
was over time
and so
already we've impacted policy so
our data in san francisco led them to
increase their cigarette tax i don't
know if any of you are smokers who are
pretty upset by that but
our data you know allows them to
generate about four million a year in uh
tax revenue
in philadelphia students who are some of
my favorite users because you know they
go out and they clean up all around
their school and they're amazing
the data that they collected was then
taken to the city of philadelphia and
used as justification to enact a
city-wide ban on plastic bags
in the netherlands we had one particular
user who was sick and fed up
with
his favorite cough drop using a plastic
wrapper
and went and documented hundreds of
thousands of pieces of litter and then
went to the brand
and took our took our data and then went
to the brand and said you need to change
and they did
so how do we do it
what do we do here
well
like i mentioned before we have a lot of
computer vision behind the scenes so we
take a picture like this and we can
identify
where and with what confidence our model
has to what type of litter is in the
picture
and then from there once we've
determined where in a picture we have
litter we run it through a number of
other models
so we have a model that detects global
brands like starbucks and
red bull and mcdonald's and you know
coca-cola and you name it right
we see we have pictures of litter from
these brands literally all over the
globe
but then we realized also that there
needs to be
regional brand models so if you're like
me and you're from the northeastern
united states or i'm from new england
originally the bottle on the left is
very identifiable as a poland spring
bottle and in its state crushed and on
the ground it's also very identifiable
because there's a lot of them
and in the middle if you're from the
united kingdom or from eastern or
western europe you might recognize that
as a cadbury wrapper
and if you've been in india or
you know a brand like maza might seem
really
you know familiar to you
but we we've had to come up with
different brand models for different
regions of the world because
litter looks different and if we really
want to understand the brand information
to be able to attribute it to its proper
source we have to do a lot of different
a lot of different things
and then we also found out
or are continuing to find out this is a
ever expanding industry and this problem
expands every day that i work
um
we have location specific models so
trash does not look the same in a
picture everywhere in the world right
this one is from the netherlands
and there's a bike in the picture which
is very appropriate i feel
but it has a different look than this
one which is from pakistan
so we found this one out because we
started doing research and our model is
just not finding anything and then we
actually looked into it realized wait
this looks totally different we have to
change our models
so now we have location specific models
as well so a lot of computer vision
so all this boils down into again this
is a technology conference so let me
talk tech for you with you for a while
our pipeline so when we ingest images
and at our you know our highest rate
during our super bowl which just
happened last last month well actually
is it october yet yes it's a technical
october so last month is world cleanup
day which i know you all celebrated like
i did i celebrated making sure our
systems didn't crash because we get
about 30 images uploaded a second during
the day
but when we take that image and we bring
it and it gets uploaded to our system
we then
use some you know cues and lambda
functions to be able to sort of like
handle
like large loads
and buffering it into an sqs queue and
then we do some spam filtering
so
this is where you know human behavior is
kind of what we do right we're talking
about littering
we never i never really imagined that
people would try to like spam our system
seems weird right with a sort of
philanthropic cause like trying to you
know but then i found out that you know
there were groups that were offering
cash prizes to people
in different parts of the world
and so people were incentivized to spam
so we have a pretty significant spam
filtering operation on the input to make
sure that people aren't taking the same
picture of litter like 20 times
using something
called the hamming distance
and so once we've determined that it's a
valid litter record
then we can process sort of the initial
intake create a thumbnail get it ready
for display on our various apps and
platforms
and then it gets into the fun bit so
once we've determined it's a proper
image once we've determined it's not
spam once we've determined it's a proper
record
then we run it through
a step function that runs it through our
initial model that creates sort of like
bounding boxes for each piece of litter
we've identified in the picture
and then for each of those pieces of
litter we run them through depending on
where it was picked up and depending on
what type the model predicted it as we
run it through various other models
and so we use aws step functions as you
can see in the diagram to be able to
handle that sort of logistical if else
and flow
traffic
and that all runs in parallel
and then once it's finished
we take all of the information from all
the various models and we come up with
our authoritative understanding of
what's in that picture
so we
to make our final decision about if we
think it's a can or if we think it's a
bottle and what brand we think it is
based on all the input from our various
models
and then we can actually publish it into
storage right and so if you can imagine
at scale this process becomes very
intensive and there's a lot of potential
places for failure and people uploading
images from my all over the world so you
know quality is different people taking
blurry pictures people not having their
location turned on
there's a whole bunch of error handling
in the midst of this this this even
though it's complicated is a vast
oversimplification of all we have to do
to figure out what if an image is valid
and process it properly
so
that's a little bit about how we take
our images how we process them and then
what we do
to be able to turn them into litter data
that then is used by our cities
so what's next
so when we look at this picture now one
of the things that we're working on
trying to extract right we have a
massive number of images and we want to
extract as much information as we can
out of them so what are we looking into
well one area that's fascinating for me
is decomposition
so this is a picture of a cigarette butt
decomposing over time
and as you can tell it looks different
as it decomposes
so one of the things we're trying to
figure out
is can we train a model to recognize not
only
what
the piece of litter in the image is
but also maybe how long it's been on the
ground
right
so how long did it take a starbucks cup
to go from when it was in our hands
and being drank to looking like this
right
we don't know how long did it take the
slug to find this mcdonald's cup at home
and be able to live inside of it
how long is that how long has that cup
been on the ground
why this is valuable is
imagine if you were a city and you knew
that at one point in time there was
litter but when did it get there and
how long did it take it to
be picked up right if we recognize that
all of our litter records are relatively
new then maybe our pickup efforts are
working versus if i find something like
this then nobody's cleaned up here in a
very very very long time right
but how long is that
and this is one of the fun things of
working in this industry because really
no one else is doing this we have to
invent a lot of things so we're having
to figure out how we can invent a
training set to be able to do this right
because we need data we have a lot of
pictures of trash i mean a lot of
pictures of litter
one of the fun parts about this talk was
actually combing through our database
and trying to find some of these
pictures but
but what can we do to create something
that's never been created before to
create a data set that nobody else has
right so it's one of the fun parts of
our job
the other thing is sort of alternative
sources right like
imagine if you are a city and instead of
doing sort of our research methodology
which maybe does a couple times a year
maybe as much as you know once a month
looking at a city and understanding the
litter pet composition on the ground
what if we attached cameras to garbage
trucks and we got an understanding you
know daily as the truck circled around
picking up litter
picking up waste sorry
what was on the ground at that point in
time
also thinking about
using drones as an alternative source to
be able to get you know a cheaper
more cost-effective way of similar kind
of litter data to what we have today
because it is expensive to pay
researchers all over the globe which is
what we do
and to be able to
you know use that data it becomes very
expensive and as you all know cities
don't have a lot of money
although they do spend a lot of money on
this but
they don't have a lot of money to spend
so we're used doing all this right
and eventually what we want to get to is
having a platform where cities can
monitor their litter so that they're not
just shooting in the dark they're not
just sort of trying to make their best
guess at what the problem is and how to
fix it
but a way to sort of understand how
their litter situation has changed over
time
and to provide them a platform to do
just that
right so that's where we're going and
that's what we're building
and of course our end goal
is so that these cities can sort of see
the unseen
and then ideally fix it
so
that's our talk you can join us and
go and download our app and start become
a member of our community and help us
out
um
also hiring the obligatory hiring slide
right you've got a you got to throw at
least one of these in there
and so we're hiring node react native
mobile a lot of computer vision
data analysts etc
so that's my talk
if you have any questions i'd love to
hear them now
that's a good point yeah we have a lot
of our database that is we can't get
brand information out of to be honest
with you because either the piece has
degraded so much or especially in the
case of marine litter
it's been
you know deconstructed beyond
recognition right
we also have a lot of things in our
database that don't have
brand information easily identifiable
like we can get some cigarette butts if
the wrapper is still on the outside of
the plastic bit
but a lot of cigarette butts we don't
have brand information
so in that case you know
we usually internally use the adage some
data is better than none so we're happy
that we got something about it right
because today they have no idea about
what's happening so yeah it's a good
question though
so have we seen the usages of the app be
um sort of maybe if i can summarize your
question sort of co-located in certain
like economic areas is that kind of what
you're getting at
or certain population centers
ah
okay so like the broken window theory so
if you see more litter then you're gonna
litter more that kind of a thing
yeah um you know we have a behavioral
scientist on our staff uh dr natalie
hollinger a little shout out um and she
is studying things like that right
that's part of the science that's not
yet sure we don't really
know why people litter right um
the idea though about sort of
correlating that with
our app data and what we find is really
interesting um it's something that you
know
is possible because there's a data set
right outside of the data set that we
have and that we're creating for cities
there isn't really a possibility to even
begin that process
but it is something that you know we
we use data sets like you know
population density and that kind of
stuff and human traffic patterns to to
use to um to influence our models i
don't know if that's exactly your
question did you was that follow up or
was that
okay
yeah yeah we're always looking for a
really good data set to correlate to
ours but it's yet another thing that
there isn't really a clear
um
even research on so we're trying to
figure that out too yes up front
how many types of litter there are
we have
let's see right now in our current
taxonomy
we have about 46
different object types that we can
recognize from a picture um for the
objects now
this might this might be amazing and the
community and just the people that are
in this area are just amazing people so
there's one guy who actually did his phd
thesis on creating a taxonomy of trash
that is the most detailed structured
hierarchical look at all of the
different types of
litter that exist
and so
yes there is a taxonomy out there
honestly at this point we're just trying
to do the best we can with the ones that
are easily identifiable because there's
a lot like if you've ever heard of a
nerdle which is a little tiny piece of
plastic that shows up a lot of times in
oceans
people really want to try to figure it
out but if you try to train a model to
find a little dot of plastic that looks
like you know the size of like a
peppercorn
it's really hard so
as much as i'd love to train a model to
do something like that
today that's just
a little bit a bridge too far today yes
uh yeah a win cowgirl is his name
yep
yeah how do we know that's a great
question um how do we know that the
images ingested by the system and run
through the models are unique that was
your question that's a fantastic
question um
it's actually really hard uh so i
mentioned um
right now there's some really simple
things that we can do like looking at
sort of the time stamps or the like the
hash of an image to see if it's exactly
the same
but there's also something
called the hamming distance that would
allow you to look at two images to
determine similarity and get a score of
similarity between two images to see
if it matches it now using that formula
at scale as another set of problems that
we're currently trying to figure out
but there's a lot of different
opportunities there
yeah
if you come work with us you can help me
solve that problem that'll be great
yes up front
yeah
so
yes so we can always get i mean with any
spam detection right as soon as you put
up like a marker someone's going to
figure out a way around it right that's
just human nature so
right now we're focusing on a single
user's information right so just making
sure that one person doesn't just like
you know send the 50 pictures of the
same thing um
but yeah i mean
i'm sure we could be more sophisticated
right now it's you know
trying to get to get the least minimum
viable product of what we can get
running running yeah
so the question was and again if i'll
try to repeat it was
what do we how do we handle the fact
that our data sets are incomplete or
maybe biased towards users that pick up
in the same general area over and over
again yeah so our community data
is flawed right so the data that we get
from our our overall community is flawed
in general so that's why we do our like
targeted research studies and we've done
research studies in 50 cities all around
the globe
and then you know 10 in the united
states
trying to create like baseline
comparisons between our community data
and the scientifically sort of proven
and statistically relevant data um and
then sort of using those two to validate
each other so to speak right um again
i'm drastically oversimplifying it but
that's basically the answer to your
question yeah
so it's a known problem but yes it's
i still i love my community right like
it's still amazing that we have people
that do this yes
yeah so um have we seen or been able to
track the rising uh homeless population
particularly on the west coast that was
your question yeah
so our data set can be used by cities in
a lot of ways um i know for a fact that
there are a number of cities that we're
talking to about are using our data set
to understand um what they term as a
legal dumping right
but you might call as like
homeless waste
you know that's
that's an ongoing use of our data and
people have found uh value in using it
in that way but you know in in many ways
we are the creator of the data set you
know how people use it
and what the sort of like uses are kind
of like you know it's so specific each
city has their own things that they care
about right like some cities might be
really focused on
waterways and leakage into waterways
other ones might be more on illegal
dumping other ones might have you know a
large tourist population and they really
care about the litter like density and
composition in their
touristy areas so
depending on where we talk in the world
each every city has their own set of
problems and so we're trying to create a
ground truth data set to allow cities to
then
use it in in ways that they can to solve
their problems
yeah okay so
um if we're recognizing particularly
brands i think is your question right um
because a can is a can as a can right um
but as far as brand how do we handle
when people sort of change their their
design of their packaging is that your
question
yeah
yeah i wish i could say that we had a
you know a nightly batch script that ran
and like pinged us on our pages when oh
the brand changed their packaging we're
not there yet um i would love it too but
but one thing that we found actually is
that our model does a really good job so
if you mentioned if you remember the
slide that had the starbucks cup that
doesn't look like an iconic starbucks
cup but our model actually did a really
good job of predicting it
because
starbucks cups although they might be
different i'm just using them as example
no shade on starbucks although they do
produce a lot of litter
you know a starbucks cup kind of even
though it has slightly different
appearances they all kind of look the
same right brand cohesion is the you
know the marketing term right so um so
that actually helps us out a lot uh so
yeah it is a problem but again like
we have so many problems to solve
out of the scope of all of them if they
we miss a couple uh new packaging it's
not uh the end of the world for us
yes uh on the back there
yeah
how did we start i mean it was that
picture of the cigarette butt right
that's how we started where our founder
took that and put it on instagram with a
tag literati and then other people
started doing it yeah i mean that's how
we started and then it's just become
kind of
you know a global movement people really
buying into the concept because i think
like
if you speak to the people and i'm not
going to ascribe their motivation but if
you speak to the people who go and pick
up a thousand pieces of trash a day
they're really motivated to see change i
hear it every day right our users i love
our users but they are passionate right
like they want their data to be used to
fix the problems that they see and they
pick up every day and so
um
yeah it starts from a oh i didn't say
the question how did it get started that
was the question okay
but but users you know really want to
see the impact and that's what we want
to provide right um and so it's
it's a balancing act between what we can
achieve today versus what we we know we
will be able to achieve in the future
yeah so one of the other things that
didn't make it onto our slides is trying
to
also have another model to be able to
determine recyclability of a of an item
that we recognize
that is also another large problem um in
the sense that
how can i say this so you know like the
one through the one through eight
plastic scale right like
very few people actually know what that
actually has anything to do with right
and the fact that a lot of that just
means it can't be recycled not that
anyway but
how do i track things like the usage of
biodegradable materials
a lot of it turns into sort of a time
series look at our object and material
compositions that we see
so if we see a lot of cups moving from
a higher correlation a higher
incidence of the combination of cup and
plastic versus cup and paper we can
determine some of those trends
but again
today cities are dealing with a massive
problem and they like that level of
nuance is lost on most people so far
right so we've done some of that look
into it but honestly no it's like
shouting into an empty room like people
are like i have bigger problems than if
they're changing that you know it would
be great too but i think people have a
lot bigger problems to solve for it so
all right i think 220 was my ending time
right yes okay all right i'm here if
anyone has more questions but thank you
for your time
[Applause]
[Music]
you